foreign
[Music]
hello everybody
um thank you so much for coming this is
Ops 200 if that's where you wanted to be
you're in the right place
um this talk is called what's new in
modern CI CD there are a lot of slides
here and a lot of text and I encourage
you to take pictures if that's easier
for you you don't have to read
everything don't stress out if you
didn't get through everything before I
continue on
um all right so let's start this
show
all right so um I'm Mia Villasenor I'm
an engineer at Google I work on devops
and CI CD products and I'm really
excited to be with you uh today and
um my colleague Nick Avery is here he's
a product manager at Google in this
space and he'll be covering the latest
from us later in the presentation and
I'll let him introduce himself then
all right so here's an overview of this
talk
um we're going to go through the basics
of cicd why this new stuff is better and
an overview of the renewed focus on
software supply chain security which
everyone's talking about including the
White House
um we're also going to talk about the
latest from Google in this space because
it wouldn't be Cloud next if we didn't
include that part so
all right so
just to level set everybody what is CI
CD
I like to talk about it like this it's
the combined practices of continuous
integration
and then either continuous delivery or
continuous deployment we'll talk about
what those mean in a second but
that's what the acronym stands for
and for those programmers in the
audience the pseudo code might make a
little more sense to you
so let's break that down right
continuous integration is the first step
of any pipeline right it's the practice
of frequently pushing all changes to a
main branch in Source control and then
running automated builds unit tests and
integration tests off of those builds
the next stage is continuous delivery
this is where that built and tested code
from the previous step is continually
delivered to a production like
environment also called staging
um you can increase the confidence that
your deploy is actually good when you
use a system like that
and then finally there's continuous
deployment and this includes all of the
previous steps but adds one crucial
additional step which is an automatic
deployed to production if all of that
testing looks good
I should note that we only see this
usually with very mature devops
organizations because you need to have
high confidence that a green light from
your pipeline means you're actually good
to go to prod and oftentimes that's not
the case
so in practice what does this actually
look like right
it all starts with the local development
environment that first line of code
and then that developer pushes that code
to Source control like Get Right
and then we hit the Ci or the continuous
integration and that's where the
building and the testing happens
and then you have either continuous
delivery or continuous deployment
depending on what you're feeling
comfortable with
and it doesn't stop there there's often
smoke testing after prod deploy and then
some
um security controls wait wait wait a
second security controls that's the last
step hold on hold on hold on I don't
think that's right I think we actually
need to um shift left right yes it's a
bit of a buzzword and that's super
annoying
but they actually have a point
if you take care of all of your Security
reviews before you get too far down that
delivery pipeline you're going to have a
much much better time
because imagine if you depend entirely
on a third-party library that is later
deemed completely unacceptable I mean
you'd have to start all over right like
what a waste of time
so modernization right like sounding
pretty good right now right
so I want to tell you a personal story
about why this is so important
so
one time I took down prod
because I did an imp deployment
incorrectly and this wasn't at Google
it was still scary
and this wasn't just one service this
was everything globally
for five minutes
scariest five minutes of my life if
you're an SRE you know this pain
so you might be wondering how that was
even possible Right
it all boils down to the fact that the
deploy was a manual process and that
required editing some text files and if
the deployment before didn't go
correctly and it wasn't cleaned up
properly then the next one would run
into trouble if you didn't check the
configs
if you've seen something like this
you're very familiar
we had a checklist of how to deploy but
that wasn't sufficient to fix a problem
that was outside the bounds of a
checklist right
so this is why we do this automation for
your pipeline repeatable builds
infrastructure as code right it all
contributes to a more stable software
delivery life cycle and stability means
happier engineers
better security and of course happy
Auditors which is a nice thing
it's also clear from data that has been
collected as part of the devops research
and assessment surveys that continuous
delivery performance actually predicts
software delivery performance which also
predicts organizational performance and
this is in like real ways that you can
measure like market share and engineer
burnout
and if you've ever submitted code to a
pipeline that takes forever only to find
out
I don't know seven hours later that your
code didn't even work right you
understand this pain
knowing when something is broken sooner
is always better for engineering
happiness and efficiency
the other thing I'd like to mention is
that high CI performance shines even
brighter when it's combined with better
security and teams that follow safe
practices and have a well-developed CI
were found to be above average in terms
of organizational performance
if you enjoyed this mix of
organizational psychology and Tech I
highly encourage you to check out
dora.dev it provides a wealth of
information that helps teams get on the
right track
and there's a little QR code here if
anyone wants to take a picture of that
these slides will also be available
later so no stress all right so let's
take a step back real quick and look at
some other challenges in traditional CI
CD elasticity
portability and maintenance
let's take a step back right there's
some challenges with traditional CI CD
right elasticity is usually the primary
concern not elastic infrastructure is
bad for performance and cost efficiency
right I want to zoom in on this graph
because I love it
during Peak if you have a static
infrastructure set up like a bunch of
build nodes that are always the same
you're not getting the performance you
want when everyone's trying to check
their stuff in and check it
and then you're also paying for idle
machines off peak right just doesn't
really make sense
and then there's the portability problem
right if you depend on plugins that are
specific to your tool and then you need
to move platforms you're locked in right
and then there's maintenance patches
repairs that's all on you
so how does Modern CI CD address these
things well it starts with portability
right with containers you run your stuff
on any Cloud any CI CD system right and
if you depend on your CI CD systems
plugins that makes migration pretty
difficult so we try to avoid that if we
can and containers are a great way to
just bring your house with you right
and then two elasticity right only pay
for what you use and get what you need
at Peak with a managed service
and then in addition to the elasticity
benefits of a managed service you also
get ephemeral environments that avoid
the headache of patching maintenance and
making sure that your environments are
secured from one another
all right
so I promised I'd talk about this
because this is a super hot topic
um supply chain security vulnerabilities
these are nasty
there are some challenges here right
because when we're talking about
software supply chain security we have
to think about the entire Spectrum
everything from that first line of code
making sure that developer locally is
authenticated to day two when that
workload is in production right
and when we look across the entire
Spectrum the number of attack factors
that can be used to compromise our
supply chain is crazy
and traditionally the far right side of
the spectrum is where we spend most of
our time and focus and we do a pretty
good job of it now in off things like
that right however
this is where we're starting to see a
problem
local Dev dependency injection issues
so there are four key challenges here
first nobody writes everything from
scratch most people pull from common
open source Frameworks and libraries and
the majority of those projects don't
require signed commits two-person code
reviews right that doesn't mean open
source is bad I love open source it just
means you have to be careful
and I'm be the first to tell you that
increased cicd automation is a great
thing but that also means an increased
number of deployments which means
increased risk
right
security has not been top of mind for
many CI CD systems for years many of
them run with root it's just easier oh I
don't know what the problem is just give
it root
and then with the increased adoption of
containers you have this proliferation
of outdated base images because
sometimes your base image is so far up
that chain that you don't even remember
how to update it anymore right
so the sheer number of possible attack
factors here and the dynamic nature of
CI CD makes this makes this hard to
protect because the security of the
entire supply chain is only as good as
its weakest link
the good news is that this space is
getting a ton of attention regulatory
bodies are getting involved and there's
a number of emerging standards as well
all right so let's go over a few
Concepts on how we're addressing this
so the three fundamental ones are
provenance
where and how it was created
transparency
what's inside that artifact
and then finally impact are we actually
effective do we need to care about this
right so let's go through each of these
and see how we can actually use these to
improve our supply chain and not just
talk about buzzwords
all right so talking about Providence
first
so there's This Acronym we came up with
called Salsa which is really funny
because we have another one called guac
right so we just like have this theme
going with like food
anyway it stands for supply chain for
software artifacts and it's a framework
under the open ssf its creation was led
by Google and in many ways it
externalizes an internal framework that
we've had for years for Borg called bab
binary authorization for Borg
think of it as a checklist of standards
and controls to prevent tampering
improve integrity and secure packages
and infrastructure
it's all about getting from where you
are today to that next level of software
supply chain security and not jump into
something crazy
the salsa guidelines are a really great
way to do this because they're divided
into several levels for incremental
adoption level zero is basically where
everyone starts no provenance at all
level one can be achieved by just
documenting your automated build process
with provenance so that it's clear how
your artifacts were built
level two requires your CI CD system to
generate and sign that provenance itself
and this is most easily done with the
hosted build platform but you can
technically do it anywhere
and then level three Builds on
everything else by adding strong
isolation between nodes they really
shouldn't be influencing each other
and the secrets that are used to sign
that provenance should not be available
to the build itself think about the
problems that could cause
so why does this matter right like this
isn't just a compliance thing that we
have to think about
we want to use this data Downstream to
actually do things right if the builders
are creating provenance stocks then we
can make decisions Downstream on whether
something should run right binary
authorization if you've heard of that we
can use this data to make decisions at
that point
and of course you know I shouldn't
mention we do support the highest level
of salsa as a V1 in our products as well
so check those out
all right so transparency is next so
salsa was all about the provenance of
our builds
bomb or software bill of materials is
about the content of those artifacts
so you can think of it as like an
ingredient list on a can of soda right
in addition to listing what's inside
that artifact s-bomb also includes
information about the provider of that
artifact and how different artifacts
relate to one another
and yes we support it in our products as
well
all right so what is the actual impact
of these software supply chain
vulnerabilities right like we've covered
provenance with salsa and artifact
transparency with s-bomb right but if
you're doing anything with even a small
amount of complexity and scale you're
gonna have vulnerabilities right and
that's often super overwhelming because
you're in this fire drill trying to
patch millions of endpoints before your
SLA for patching is over right
and that's where Vex comes in
Vex stands for vulnerability
exploitability exchange and it's an
additional standard that brings context
to this whole situation basically if
there are vulnerabilities in the
software depending on the call graph
they might not even be reachable or
exploitable so what's the point in
patching them right
and it does this with what's called
impact statements avec's impact
statement provides a way for us to
indicate that a specific vulnerability
is not impacting the specific
application because of X it gives a
reason
you don't just have to believe it right
a good example of this is a
vulnerability that is specific to a
runtime like wassum for example if your
app is distributed as a container image
on gke it's probably not exploitable
so our approach to supply chain Security
on Google cloud is twofold one
we want to integrate these time tested
practices based on Open Standards and in
put them in our products bake them and
make it easy to use
and we're focused on the open source
Community as well and we provide
leadership around things like standards
salsa technology osv scanner fuzzing
shared open source
and we integrate software supply chain
security at every step in our pipelines
right all of these products work
together and secure your software supply
chain because it's only as strong as
that weakest link
we look at the space in four parts
the first is the local developer
experience I think a lot of people
forget about that but it's actually
super important right
secure access to Source control is a
difficult problem to solve right verify
an identity
scan you for vulnerabilities and
licensing information at the time that
that information is introduced into your
system
two the supply of artifacts needs to be
scanned and verified to be clean and you
can do this yourself with our artifact
analysis offering or there's assured
open source as well which does a lot of
that work for you
and then cicd is where the salsa s bomb
Vex stuff comes into play you want to
make sure that you're generating signed
artifacts with proper metadata
and then finally at runtime we want to
make sure that deploy systems are
incorporating admission controls that
use that metadata we talked about
earlier
to actually make decisions on whether
something should run
and then all of these areas are
underpinned by a unified set of policy
controls
all right so let's dive a little bit
deeper into some of these that are my
favorite
so managed local Dev right this is
something that I think the industry as a
whole needs to think a little bit more
about our solution to secure local Dev
is this thing called Cloud workstations
which provides cloud-based Dev
environments for existing gcp customers
this is an extension of the cloud shell
that you know and love but we support
running those workstations on your own
VMS in your VPC instead of using our
resources
and this benefits two types of people I
think this is really great for a central
devops team that can automate management
and security policies for their team's
Dev environments like with workstation
templates
and then also developers have an
on-demand pre-configured workstation
right the the days of oh it works on my
machine are gone because everyone has
the same machine right
so continuing with that local Dev Story
there's this thing Cloud code Source
protect which brings dependency
vulnerability and license awareness
directly into the IDE without blocking
productivity
and this all seamlessly works with Cloud
workstations because it's just a VM
right
with these two things together your
central devops teams and developers can
securely manage developer environments
and create secure applications
this is currently in private preview but
if you talk to your account rep I'm sure
they can set you up with something
all right so
let's learn about the latest from Google
and I have Nate here to walk you through
that thanks so much
[Applause]
okay so uh I know some of you flew in
last night maybe you flew in this
morning
and it's been a long day
and I am the only thing standing between
all of you and happy hour
great
so I'm going to let you in a little
secret
we have release notes with a lot of the
stuff in it
so if you happen to feel parched
you can go to the docs but uh if you
want to hear about why some of these
features are like really cool and why we
think that they're compelling and why
we believe that they're going to enhance
your experience then please stick around
I'll try to make it go quick though
all right everything starts off with the
basic CI CD pipeline it reads from left
to right you have your IDE in this case
that's going to be Cloud Workstation
paired with Cloud code we have a source
code repository we have build handled by
Cloud build
we have artifact analysis and artifact
registry for your package handling needs
as well as your security vulnerability
scanning and then Cloud deploy is a
dedicated tool built for deployment and
then we have our run times so that's gke
Cloud run all those really cool modern
ones where we can do things like the
binary authorization
so let's talk about Cloud build
as you can see there's a lot here
this isn't
quite everything that it does but these
were a lot of features that were
released over the last year or so
and before we talk about some of the
specifics
um well let's just handle some of the
basics about call build
Cloud build is our CI solution
and it's meant for Automation and it is
unopinionated and by that we mean you
can set up your tasks any way you want
to find by us
every one of the build steps as an
ephemeral container and those containers
share a common workspace which allows
you to actually pass information across
from one to the other
so earlier Mia told you about salsa and
she told you that cloud build handles
salsa
so
we're going to move on
I told you I'm gonna try to make this
work
so binary authorization binary
authorization is pretty cool and I know
a lot of folks and are talking with them
they don't always turn it on and some of
that is because there's like a fear
maybe it works maybe it doesn't
but let's try to remove that fear by
talking about it a little bit more and
helping you understand what's happening
it works
you can think of it as a series of
trust-based policies right you say
I want this to be the thing that blocks
a container from running
and that thing can be described
in a couple of different ways usually
it's going to be defined using all of
the stuff we told you about before like
salsa s-bombs vex
all of that so you could say yeah I want
to stop
anything that has a security rating of
high or greater
you could also say
I only want to run things that were
built in Cloud build right so you have
the opportunity to make that work
however you want and if you take a look
at the binary authorization
configuration page you can also run it
in a dry run mode where you can just
kind of take a look at it see what would
have happened had you had it running and
those results will be in the logs
okay
so again the the big six of it is that
if something shouldn't be running then
it'll stop it
and that's really the whole idea of this
you want to make sure that the thing
that you've developed
is secure over here
as it's built it maintains its integrity
and when it's running it is still that
same thing
foreign
and this is actually on your runtime gke
or Cloud run
you're going to get one of these really
cool security insights panels it's
alerts what you saw before
however this is when
you know content that's actively running
it'll analyze your kubernetes
configurations against the Pod specs
security standards
within highlight any deviations that it
finds pretty much what's wrong with my
environment you know am I good to go
okay let's go back to some of these
other features
um
I work in product
and so I can tell you that once a
product is launched
things happen
um we learn a lot about how people
really use these products in the real
world and in this case uh
but Trend just started really taking
over and I know all of you know it is
infrastructure as code
and what we found out was that people
really really wanted to use terraform
to create infrastructure as code
for everything including how their
pipelines are built so that was one of
the features we added it was a very well
uh
well received feature I'll say
every now and then we get to do some
things that you know customers really
like and this was one of them uh
we'll move on
so Cloud builds free tier this is
something that's out there you're all
encouraged to try it you can get a lot
as you can see you get 2 500 pre-built
minutes per month and one of the other
things that we've done
I think I can go back real quick
the E2 standard 2 default machine type
is Now the default
um
it's a lot
it's kind of redundant
but what it means is that you're going
to get a faster built machine right
and so that will actually help you
in your processes get things going in
your CI CD pipeline hopefully in things
a little bit faster from the perspective
of your of your builds
next we'll talk artifact but I just read
an analysis
which are there okay up top
a little bit of background for those of
you who uh may not be too familiar with
them we used to have this product called
container registry
and can on registry was really nice but
it did what it said it stored containers
and as time went on we realized that
people needed to store more than
containers they need to store
application packages along with them
maybe they needed to store OS packages
along with those and so now we have
artifact registry which is a universal
package management system
it tries to cover everything and in that
it also ties into our security controls
so that CMAC vpcsc
auditing and vulnerability scanning the
vulnerability scanning by the way comes
from artifact analysis and that same
artifact analysis provides scanning at a
couple of other layers in the system
here's a list of a few of the features
in AR
and judging by the number of folks who
signed up for some of the pre-ga
features uh we knew that some of these
were going to um to land fairly well uh
for instance remote and virtual
repositories
um cleanup policies was another one
and the other thing that happened was
while we were releasing new formats like
yum app go you know some of the other
ones
uh
some folks said well what if we have
something that's not one of those
so now there's also going to be a
generic type available
that should cover hopefully
a lot more the folks and really make it
that Universal tool that is intended to
be
okay so we'll talk about virtual and
remote repositories
this feature strengthens this
strengthens sorry
I'm tired a little parched
um your dependency governance and
simplifies this and simplifies access to
Ports
all that really what it says is going to
give you like a universal URL to your
repos
remote repos on the other hand point to
an upstream repo so
we'll go to this guy
let's say I have a simple python app
that I made up
uh
what I would do is I'll configure some
of those packages
for the ones that I've created to be
stored in my standard repo
I'll create a a remote repo that pulls
anything that can't be found
from Pi Pi
and then I'm going to use a virtual repo
underneath that
that I point everything towards
so
In The End by using that one point
I've lowered a lot of the cognitive
overhead of a developer they don't have
to remember all the different URLs all
the links to figure out where to get
packages but then something else really
cool happens
and that's
you kind of see it over here
there's a priority tab
uh priority column
you can set the priorities such that it
tells
which one should be pulled first
so in a lot of cases what you're going
to want is to look at your local repo
before it goes out to a third party repo
once more there's a quick reminder
that we have scanning which can be run
on push
we also have scanning that can be run on
demand for a variety of package types
cleanup policies
it's pretty obvious I mean it you know
we put it right there on Front Street
it's for cleaning up files in your
registry
um
it's really neat though because it does
more than just Define policies for
deletion you can also Define which files
to keep
uh
you can apply up to 10 of these policies
per repo
and they're defined with Json
pretty basic stuff
this right here is what a delete policy
looks like
not a whole lot there you know if you
know Json yep that's what you expect
this is what a cleanup policy looks like
it actually
looks pretty darn similar
what you'll notice though is that in a
keep policy the action type is a type
keep
okay Cloud deploy
there's one thing I want to mention
before I really get into Cloud deploy
and that's the fact that this whole
system here
they're made up of individual
applications and any of these
applications can be replaced with a
third-party tool now
we're not going to fight you if you want
to use all Google tools but if you have
something that you prefer to use for
your builds if you have something that
you prefer to use for your artifact
scanning and Analysis and storage or you
just think you have a better deployment
tool that's fine it's
it's we're trying to make it so that
will meet you where you are
feel free you can swap out Parts as you
go you don't have to do it all at once
in a big bang
foreign
it's an interesting product Cloud deploy
some folks don't quite get it when they
come to it it can be a little bit
a little bit challenging because
it is focused specifically on deployment
that's what it does it doesn't do builds
it just does deployments
however it does it really really well
right it does it in an opinionated way
now opinionated here means that it has
certain best practices and policies and
all that stuff kind of built into it
and this is a list of all the features
of cloud deploy that that were launched
in the last year
team's been super busy just crank it
away and there's a lot here
um
okay yeah verifications there SDS
insights
almost everything that's here
is designed for making sure that you
have a very fluid capability to deploy
onto our modern runtimes like gke as
well as Cloud run
and the other thing that's really neat
about this is that the team goes extra
far and that they want to make sure that
those features that work for one of the
runtimes will work for all of the run
times
where possible
so we talk about Canary
um I think most of you know what a
canary is but real quick a canary
deployment is a progressive rollout of
an application that splits traffic
essentially you have one that's already
running and then you want to have a new
version so there's some percentage of
traffic to split out to a new one
with Canary and Cloud deploy it's up to
you to set what those thresholds are you
can start with five percent ten percent
25 percent whatever you want it's up to
you you figure out
um whatever it whatever it takes to make
you feel comfortable
knowing that the deployment is safe
we'll now talk about parallel deploy
this was really cool
um affects different people different
ways but
what it does is it allows you to deploy
to multiple clusters at the same time
so let's say you've got a cluster on the
east coast and you have a cluster on the
west coast uh you can drop the same uh
deployment onto both of them
we also have deploy parameters
so this works in conjunction with
parallel
so if we go back to that example of east
and west maybe there's a little more
traffic running on the East Coast so I
will set a number of nodes at eight and
there's a little bit less traffic on the
west so I will set that at six
and that's perfectly possible
you can that's that's just one of the
examples but
when you really start looking at things
most deployments get sticky at points
and parameters can be a big help
deploy hooks
this is another one of those features
that was added to address real world
deployment needs
real quick they are user-defined actions
that can run either before
or after or both before and after your
deployment
so
like how sorry uh
I remember doing deployments back in the
day when I needed to
maybe update a database schema before I
could run my deployment so that would be
a pre-deploy hook maybe I had a custom
script that I needed to run after the
deployment that would be a post deploy
hook
what's really neat is that it takes a
lot of those
things those tasks those chores that we
used to do
maybe outside of the deployment tool it
brings them back into it so that you
actually have really nice automated
system that automates all the stuff you
need and not just parts of it
oh this one here
in console onboarding
this one is one of my favorite features
because
um
I will admit something real quick when I
first came to the team
I tried to launch Cloud deploy and I
walked through it and I realized I could
not create a pipeline using the GUI
it was weird I thought it was weird
but you know there was there was
thoughts behind it you know there's a
lot of
there's a lot of thought put into all of
the applications
but I kind of walked away from it
thinking
I'll get back to it later and so
I happen to know from talking to folks
that
I wasn't the only one so if previously
you did what I did and said I'll check
it out later
you now can do that it works really
smooth it's in the GUI run through it
once get your idea for but for what
works
maybe do a quick POC and then if you
really want to do it after that you can
jump into the yaml files
and one last note
we believe in this tool so much
so much so that the price has been
adjusted
um
and this is really something that goes
along with an overall feature that we
want which is accessibility we want
folks to feel like they can come to
these tools and give them a run and
improve their experience
and we realize that price is a big part
of that so
now I want to make sure I say this right
so I don't get in trouble with legal
um you can use pipelines with a single
deployment Target at no cost
single Target no cost but then anything
other than that if you need a more full
fully fleshed out pipeline those have
been dramatically reduced in terms of
price so really at this point it's a
really cool product to jump into between
the price change and the GUI setup we're
really doing whatever we can to
make it easier for folks to at least
take a look at it
so to wrap it up
there are a few things that happened in
a modern pipeline
and we all have some technical debt
that's already in there
what we're hoping to do is to provide
you with tools that at least
reduce how much technical debt you have
going forward
that's really kind of the goal
so if any of you are out there and you
have blockers to that or you found some
things that you don't quite like about
the tools that's fine most of us are
available in social media circles
we'll be downstairs in the booth I think
I've got both days Wednesday and
Thursday
uh just come by tell us tell us what you
like tell us what you don't like
um because the team takes that feedback
very seriously
so thank you
[Music]